[Music]
so thank you for taking a time for our
assistance it is infuse your business
with machine learning
I'm cattle and I'm black Lakshmanan
yeah we are going to have this is just
by us our me interest at first myself at
first so I'm a casa too I'm a developer
advocate for Google Kratt I have been
working at Google for six years and for
last two years I have been working as a
developer advocate with rack evangelist
for the purpose so I usually have my
talk at meetups and sessions were deep
in practice and talks about Google
products especially for the DTO nargis
project such as Google bigquery and
machine running products and for the
first of all I'd like to going through
the all the basics about machine
learning and neural networks and I will
ask I will pass the stage to deck for
you run the latter part of the session
okay so I'd like to start with the
question of what is machine learning how
many people have used machine learning
in this venue about how people like a
50% of people how many people have you
tried the neural network
oh it's about 30th person racket 21
century yeah it's kind of average I ask
these questions every time I have the
decisions in many events so maybe
usually recent 10 percent if it's a
usual web developer conference recent
impasse it has experience with the
neural network so what is machine
learning machine learning is all about
data and how to have the predictive
inside from data by using the algorithms
of machine learning algorithms so rather
than you know going through the scanning
the old past data you want to have any
predictive inside you want to predict
about futures based on the past the
history of the data so to do that you
want to use the machine learning
algorithms that is using the different
computing part time from the existing IT
systems so let me start with the very
interesting demonstration called
playground to understand what is the
difference between the huge
IT systems and the machine learning if
you have the this this kind of data sets
father how do you crash by them what
kind of the program code you would write
to crush by these two data points where
we have X 1 and X 2 2 inputs and if you
plot the data points you can see there
are the two groups blue groups and
orange groups maybe you can think them
over a number of the height and number
of the widths of people so that you can
have the groups of adults where people
have the higher Heights and higher
weights and people with children where
you have the lower with and lower height
and if you are a programmer and you are
asked to classify these two group of
data data points you may want to draw an
diagonal Ryan rectus at the arbitrary
position to check the famous red shows
whether the each data points exceeds the
threshold on that it which exceeds the
threshold you must be an adult if is not
exceeding this ratio must be not child
but the thing is that with the
traditional IT systems the all the
programmers is responsible to instruct
computers how to solve this problem with
in some arbitrary parameters rec ways
and biases so by choosing the right W 1
W 2 ways you can you know change the
angle of the destroy try and by choosing
the right bias or threshold you can move
the position of the rise that is how the
usual programmers would write his or her
call to solve this problem but how the
neural networks can serve these
particular problems let's take a look at
the real demonstration where is it I
lost it
was it I think I think I crossed the
window swing I finished the last talk
sorry about machine learning
demonstration all the most racially yes
yeah this is the very interesting
demonstration called playground where
you can you can design your own neural
network inside browser and train it in
real time and where did we have this is
we here we have the one neuron here so
it is not an attack it's just a neurons
we have and we have two inputs X 1 and X
2 as an input features and we have a
bunch of the training data here and this
look at how the neural network network
can be trained by using training data
you see if you I click the training
start button then gradually the diagonal
I try to move to classify the data
points in a correct way
the usual results the initial parameters
are randomly selected in machine
learning algorithms but the optimization
algorithms of the machine learning is
tries to tweak the parameters like a W 1
and W 2 and bias to find the best way to
draw a straight line to crush crush with
these points so if you are programmer
maybe you think that it's much faster to
write the program code and specify a
certain weights and biases by yourself
but you do not in machine Bannock you
met computer sinks by itself to find the
what's the answer was it may be let me
notice it to the other yeah that's much
better
so what the new one did is to choose the
right combination of the weights and
biases so what did you run did was
exactly the same things you would have
done when you're writing a cross for
solving a cross creation problem so the
single neurons takes any number of the
inputs rec X 1 X 2 2 X n and marks price
those inputs visited weights record
weight 1 W 1 W 2 W N and multiply those
inputs with weights and that's exactly
the same things you would have done with
your program code but the huge
difference here is that you let the
computer try to find the best
combination of the parameters by using
these technologies you can even have a
single neuron crash by an handwritten
text image if you have a bunch of 100
text image in grayscale you can just use
a single neurons you don't have to build
a whole surface sketch a deep in your
networks you could just have single
neuron to classify those images how do
you do that at first you have to convert
all the grayscale images into a bunch of
any numbers so as you can see the this
grayscale image which has 20 x 28 and 28
the dimensions you can convert them
other 780 phone numbers in a single
vector and put them all into an into a
neural network or numeron as an input of
the aurigean neuron and Mark Prior is
the weights from W 1 to W 784 and takes
this summation of everything so it's a
very basic simple mathematics and if the
summation the value of the summation
exceed certain thresholds you can think
that image must be a number digit of 1
or digital 8 just like that and by
training the neural network by using the
tens of thousands of the training images
handwritten text you can have a neural
network generate very unique pattern as
you can see on the screen where these
are the deep patterns you can see in the
weights after the training where the
blue color represents the positive value
and a red color represents the negative
value so for example if you take a look
at the weights for the number 0 you can
see the these zero rack patterns blue
patterns is automatically generated in
the weights and historically if you want
to do the image analytics or imagery
combinations so those professional for
image recognition has been trying to
find the best filters or patterns to do
to detect any objects in images so that
is where the people the human
programmers have to put all the
knowledge ease and experience on that
but the most important things what
happening we are in the AI blooming
right now is we are now letting the
neural networks to find what with the
best pattern best the filter to crush
find this problem so you don't have to
have humans or programmers to generate
those spíritus these filters is
automatically generated and after
applying those ways as filters and
adding in some biases and you can get
the result like this if you have the
image of seven the probability is forty
seven will be the highest axis and I was
talking about a single neuron so you can
use the single noodles to have Noorani
to new neurons to recognize and hydrogen
extracted like I said like explained and
now you can have more and more numerous
between the input data and output data
to make the neural network much smarter
this is called hidden bear what is that
they are excited let me open these
second demonstrations I will need just
being you must to solve this problem so
here we have a single hidden layer here
and we have three noodles individual
areas and we have another problem here
the training data for classifying
problem when we have Punjab the blue
dots inside this supplement of the
orange group and for humans it's really
easy to understand the underlying did
the patterns in the training data set so
just you can watch the data set and you
can easily tell that the blue is inside
the orange group it's easy but it's not
so easy for the programs to understand
this pattern especially for the single
neuron because a single neuron can only
draws a straight line in the 2d space so
it can classify the problems into two
spaces its so-called linear
classification but this is a nonlinear
problem this is a nonlinear problem so
where we have to use the hidden layers
to dissolve them so by starting the
training of the neural networks you can
see the neural network gradually trying
to capture the patterns hidden inside it
as a practice remit write game this so
you see the computer is trying to find
the optimal way to capture the patterns
and if you take a look at what each
noodles are doing then you can see each
you know is doing very straight or very
simple linear classification for example
these particular noodles just draw the
arize to classify each data point is in
a blue area or white area again this new
ones doing the same thing during a story
try and do the linear classifications
whether the data points in the left or
right and that's it so very simple but
having the multiple layers of newman's
you can have the neurons in the higher
layer like here here we have a single
neurons as an output layer it can take
the all the atoms from the numerous in
the hidden layer so that it can make
little bit smarter decision on
classifying the data points it can
listen to really what each neuron is
saying from the first layer and make a
final decisions because this neuron says
is saying this thing this neuron says
these things so that the final you know
can make a much smarter decision like
this and if you put more and more new
ones here the decisions will be much
more smarter so as you see the now
neural networks is smart enough to
capture the very sophisticated polygons
inside the data set
does New Zealand a yes - hidden a yes is
mapping inputs to defeated space and
classify with a hyperplane and this
diagram says so much about this
statement so if we have the complex
problem like this you cannot use single
new ones to classify this because it
cannot be classified by the by the
single straight why so that you'd have
the you may want to have the you know in
the hidden layers the hidden layers
numerous in the hidden layers can tweak
the input data to make it easier for the
final numerals to cross by the data with
davinia classification practice so the
final neuron can just draw a story try
to classify the sauce tweak'd tweaked to
dataset again if you have this kind of
the nonlinear dataset you have by having
the three hidden animals in the hidden
layer so students can tweak the data so
that the final new is tries to make it
easier for the final neuron to draw a
straight no flat plane in the 3d space
like a flood plain here to cross by the
red part and brought it
mission details about the how the hidden
layer can tweak your data to extract a
future self you see even if you have a
very complex structure inside dataset
the hidden layer can try to tweak the
data in every dimensions to make it
crash viable
so by using these technologies you can
even have this double spiral problem
Laguna's party neural networks let's
take a look at the actual demonstration
for this we go to the third
demonstrations here we have much complex
now we have the three hidden layers
is much more complex the devil is called
stubble spiral so if you as long as I
using the traditional IT program
language it's really hard to solve this
problem if you if you want to stop this
program by using the Java or Python with
the ordinary programming paradigm do you
want to write many statements with many
thresholds to check whether each data
point is in this area this area maybe
you can do that by writing tens of the
statements but I wouldn't do that
instead I want to use neural networks to
solve this problem because by taking
some times especially computing power
and training data set the computer can
gradually extract your hidden patterns
inside it it just says just like you're
watching right now
initially the neural networks cannot
understand what's going on inside
dataset but if you keep teaching the
neural networks then the neuronal
network tried to tweak'd all the weights
and biases increasing or decreasing each
weights and biases little bit and see
which direction would be the best way to
converge to all the ways and combination
of division biases and now you see the
neural network training is converging
and now you get the neural networks
smart enough to solve this problem and
again if you take a look at what each
neurons are doing in the neural networks
the neurons in the past record is doing
very simple things towards to try and
crush value to the points in two areas
in yours in the second way here doing
really smart in the newest newest can
recognize repeats complex pattern and
further here you can see much smarter
neurons and
today yeah you could you can have a
single Raya that is smart enough to
cross by the double spiral just like
humans do so this is how the neural
network works and this is the reason why
the deep neural networks can sometimes
exceed human performance because it's
not instructed by humans as long as you
keep instructing computers how to solve
a particular problem it cannot exist
human performance but if you read the
computers try to find the best way to
solve a particular problem sometimes
it's possible that computers can find
the best way to extract the feature to
solve each problem so that was my part
so I directed pass it pass this is to
lack Thank You Kass so my name is lack
I'm part of the professional services
organization at Google and I've been
doing machine learning pretty much all
my career so whenever I see this slide
it always like sets me back because the
very first thing that I did out of
college I used to work at no other us
were the research urgency and building
models and I started out doing image
processing
so when Kass said you know you know
people would write filters that people
was me right so out of college I was
writing image processing filters to find
thunderstorms and radar images and we
basically develop all of these image
processing filters by hand my no my PhD
was in texture processing and so then
when you then go ahead and you look at a
deep neural net and you basically say
when you look at a deep neural at the
first parts of a neural net are about
basically finding edges you're basically
finding very simple shapes and the next
part of the neural net is about finding
more complex shapes and so on my work
was essentially probably around the
third layer of the neural network but if
you go look at modern-day image
classification neural network the number
of layers ranges to about 130 hundred
and forty layers okay so you can kind of
imagine
what goes through my mind every time I
look at and Mardin your network and to
basically think we were working on these
such things very primitively the second
part of the story is of course neural
networks have been around since the
1970s so we could have used neural
networks where I did and I did I
basically did we did a whole bunch of
things with neural networks and I
remember our conversation many years ago
where we said hey instead of was doing
all these filters by hand why don't we
just throw the raw pixels out of our
radar images into a neural network and
have it figure it out and then we all
had a big laugh because how could you
ever get the computational power
required to throw your raw pixels into
your neural network can you imagine the
number of layers that's gonna need how
on earth are you gonna program and
you're a network to optimize hundreds of
layers come on right this is like
ridiculous we have to go back and start
designing our filters again fast-forward
a few years and here we are right we're
basically you know we can now launch
know a jupiter notebook and we basically
have one of my colleagues here doing a
demo right that basically trains on a
thousand images to classify flowers he
gets the entire demo done in like an
hour
you basically can classify a set of
images get it all trained and you
basically move on to the next thing in
your life
that's essentially what the cloud gives
you right the combination of machine
learning and the the computational power
of the cloud is what allows us to solve
the kind of problem so we're Kaz is a
developer advocate he's basically goes
out and his role at Google is to
basically get everybody enthusiastic to
about doing things and basically
explaining how neural networks work and
how we can do them I'm on the
professional services end and the people
I deal with are always asking that what
kind of problems can it solve right what
can I do with it right and my answer is
hint it's about the alternative it's
about the things that the alternative
when I started in my career right
instead of using a neural network the
alternative was
that I wrote heuristic rules image
processing filters but that same concept
carries through to a variety of other
situations here for example is Descartes
lab Descartes lab is one of GCP
customers they wanted to basically look
at Landsat imagery so know you have
Landsat imagery they want to look at the
imagery and looking at the imagery they
wanted to basically determine how much
corn or soybean yield was gonna happen
across the entire country because
commodities prices a variety of things
depend on how much food actually gets
grown well by looking at these Landsat
images right even before the harvest
happened they were able to basically
predict the corn yield and the soybean
yield and they were able to do it five
months before the actual USDA report
came out that said this is how much got
done right you basically changed the
input the input used to be you harvested
the like all of the stuff and you
measured how much went to market
instead the input for decart lab was
let's just image the earth let's use the
images of the earth to basically figure
out where all the farms are and how much
right look at the greenery content look
at how these things change and they
could use historical data they had
previous years of data from variety of
different locations and they could
basically use that to train their model
and they could basically do the
prediction so the first thing to think
about is is there a different way to do
it right one way to do it would be to
basically wait and wait for the analysis
wait for the data to get collected the
other way is to say can this information
that I'm going to be doing can I get it
it from some other way and there's some
other way for decart lab was Landsat
images another so there's these kinds of
use cases are all across a variety of
industries so whether you're in
manufacturing you're in travel you're in
retail you're an energy you're basically
looking at what data do I have and how
can I use that data to basically go
ahead and predict or estimate
something that I don't already know or
something that I will know like in the
decart lab they would know the corn
yield accepted to take them five months
to know it and this is the way to
basically get to know it earlier by
taking advantage of data and as Cass
pointed out the thing to realize is that
don't get like no don't get constrained
by the way you're doing things now the
way a human would solve it right is not
necessarily the way the computer would
solve it so you you can easily imagine
feeding a computer different type of
data set than the one that you're
currently doing in using for analysis
okay so think about the data that is
somewhat predictive somewhat correlated
with what's actually the thing that you
want to predict so remember I taught
started with think about it's about the
alternative Eric Schmidt you all heard
him today I'm an amazing speaker when I
grow up I want to speak as well as Eric
Schmidt is for it speaks so Eric Schmidt
last year at GCP next he basically
talked about machine learning
he said machine learning this is the
next transformation it's the next
transformation for a lot of companies
and the programming paradigm the way we
program stuff is gonna change the way we
program stuff today is that we write
rules we write if-then rules we write
Louvre we write iterations we write
logic into our programs and Eric Schmidt
saying that's gonna change instead of
programming your computer you're gonna
show it a bunch of data right you're
gonna basically tell it to learn
something and the computer is basically
going to then do what you want yeah this
is an interesting quote because you have
the two trees know lots of fully from
thoughts here about what machine
learning is but there is no word in
there about the thing that we normally
think of as machine learning which is
learning from data he's basically taking
I think where do you start
think about the heuristics and the rules
that you currently base your business on
and see if you can do those things in a
different way so it's about the logic
so figure out what you want to do
differently and then collect the data
you need to do it that way
wait so start not with the data start
with the problem you want to solve the
problem you often want to solve is a
problem of scalability because human
heuristics hand-coded heuristics don't
really scale very well yeah so how this
is basically borne out of Google
experience the way Google search used to
work was you would go to the search bar
and because someone would say Giants and
we need to show you some results and as
we all know like the top results on
Google are very valuable right so we
want also we have one be very thoughtful
about what is the top result we want to
give our searchers the right result so
the way we do this was well some
research for Giants and if they are do
we return them San Francisco Giants or
do we return them New York Giants well
there was a rule and the rule was of the
query our Giants and that the user is
located in the Bay Area show them
results about San Francisco Giants if
the query is Giants and the user is
located in New York
show them result about New York Giants
if the user is not in the Bay Area users
not in New York show them results about
big tall people right that was basically
the rule that was in the Google search
engine for one query about Giants
think about how many queries happen for
every sports team for every River
someone searches for the Red River there
in Texas we show you the river between
Oklahoma and Texas if the person is in
Minnesota we show you the Minnesota Red
River right so every geographic feature
stadiums names of businesses right and
this is just about location this is just
about location you have so many other
cues about your interests so you can
easily imagine I just just imagine how
big and complex and hairy that could
this gets
it's not tractable and that's when
rankbrain came along so rankbrain was
let's not hard code rules instead let's
see if we can do things in a better way
we have data right we know that when we
show people results we know right what
they actually clicked on and let's use
it to train a model to basically predict
right using a whole host of inputs let's
make a neural network to go ahead and
predict what the top result ought to be
so we were replacing all of those
heuristic rules by a neural network and
that neural network as soon as it got
released then it essentially became the
third most important signal among
hundreds of signals that decide what the
ranking of the page is going to be on
the fine on the Google search result
that's basically what what Eric Smith is
driving at when he says that machine
learning is a new way of programming
right but because what we are doing is
that we're replacing the way we do logic
and we're replacing the way we do logic
and starting with that right know when
you're successful in the thing that the
company is most famous for everybody
takes notice right so four years ago in
2012 there's pretty much no deep
learning models in Google right
as quarter for 2016 we're basically at
4,000 models right and this is all over
all of Google products Apps Gmail maps
photos you guys have seen it everywhere
and it becomes this thing that you
basically get everybody in this mindset
of we may be doing things using a
seat-of-the-pants rule now but we're
gonna collect the data so we can do it
with machine learning later
that's essentially gonna be the approach
that every product team takes the every
product team essentially says how can we
solve this problem with ml so we don't
have to keep writing rules and handling
specific
and specific you know if this if there
are all those situations we want to
avoid that by doing ml right so you
basically get into this process of how
do I collect the data so the my point
here is that you start with a problem
you want to solve think about the
scalability of your logic and then think
about what data you need to collect to
solve it okay so first we write in Fiona
infuse your business with machine
learning the first thing to do is to
rethink your user input right rethink a
user input what do I mean by that
but you on one hand you have custom
machine learning models with tensorflow
with machine learning engine with just
friend GA today right so you can
basically build your own machine
learning models on the other hand
building your own machine learning
models requires lots and lots and lots
of data so when we talk about you want
to build an image classification model
you need millions of images but we have
ways to basically do things with fewer
images right we also have water pre
train machine learning models in the
vision API which is basically already
knows how to classify lots of images we
have the speech API which already knows
how to transcribe text it is a waste of
your time and resources to go build a
speech model it's you might just use MML
model that we have trained over lots and
lots of data so when you look at our
video API that got demoed today that's
not on my slide yet right so that's
basically on trained on so many more
videos then it's even possible for you
to think about right in terms so there
are better things for you to do
everywhere all of us are in businesses
we have core focus so those are the
things that we want to focus on the
things that Google has done you want to
take advantage of and that's where the
free train models come in so number one
let your users talk to you the days when
you could have expected your users to
come in and type
are gone okay these days right on when
if I want to go somewhere I'm basically
on on Google Maps right I pretty much
never ever type the name of the place
I'm going to it's all just voice search
right especially because I'm on the go
it is completely completely voice search
and you know maybe I'm on the leading
edge but a huge fraction of searches on
mobile happen through voice and when you
build applications increasingly your
users are going to expect the same thing
okay so for example there's a company
called oak net which wanted to basically
build the system that needed to figure
out how much is my car worth so people
have done this before right
but what Achmed said was I'm going to
rethink my user input and what I'm gonna
do is you want to figure out how much
your car is worth take a photograph of
your car take the photograph of the
front of your car of your dashboard of
the back of the sides everything take a
bunch of photographs send it to us will
tell you how much the car is worth so
from the photographs akhmet will
determine like the model of the car who
made the car which year it was there at
the condition of the car all of that
stuff and tell you this is what it's
worth now put yourself in somebody
situation right you're a consumer you
have two possible web websites one
websites gives you a form that's two
pages long another website says send me
a couple of photographs right you
obviously see that now ml is a
competitive advantage it rethink your
user input your user input doesn't need
to be forms ready user input doesn't
need to be forms how many of you use
Google Forms
quite a few of you right and have you
noticed that recently rarely if you're
creating a Google Form you can say for
example right you asked a question when
do you want to meet and it Auto suggests
answers right it Auto suggests possible
answers it helps you dynamically build
stuff right and that's essentially the
kind of stuff that we're talking about
we're talking about being able to know
right and prove limit the amount of user
input that somebody has to give you
because you can kind of in in to guess
what their next question or the next
answer is going to be here's another
example right of using images to take
actions the applications called meeting
nany okay
which basically has a camera on a
conference room the same camera that's
used for video conferencing okay it's
connected to the calendar so all it does
is basically looks at the room so the
meeting was supposed to start seven
minutes later nobody has shown up it'll
release the room so somebody else can
come use it yeah so using images to take
action the user input here is all
completely automated but it's an image
it's an image it's an image of the room
so it can figure out if you can do this
or not
okay and another customer frost Accardo
the way okada used to work or somebody
sends an email you have somebody sit
there read the email figure out what was
in the email and decide what to do the
way they do it now is that they used the
natural language processing API again a
pre-built model the NLP API modeled they
were able to use it and they can use
that model to basically say oh here's an
here's an email that came in and this
email is a customer expressing
satisfaction so this is what I need to
do this is that this is something that's
about building the customer is
frustrated about building so I need to
try a jet set it to somebody who handles
billing right so an email comes into the
company it automatically gets triads
sent to the right Department this is the
kind of stuff that your customers are
going to increasingly expect
right do not you're not gonna be able to
get away with form responses that are
like just you know boilerplate stuff it
needs to be really really really
meaningful responses and you can do this
you can do this now with machine
learning
another example here okay lots of us
right when we build applications we ask
for customer images that's a scary thing
because we're all know be working in a
variety of different industries that
have regulatory stuff okay so here's a
customer right that wanted to basically
prevent violent images from being
uploaded okay and you know they also
wanted to prevent like unsafe for work
images and here's an example of the
vision API at work it's able to focus in
on the image on the left and say okay
this is actually a safe image it's just
showing you a couple on a beach but the
image on the right
it basically Flags as being unsafe and
it turns out that if you look at what
the machine learning algorithm is
focusing on that's the yellow stuff and
the red stuff it's focusing on the
finger of the person holding the gun and
apparently the person is squeezing the
trigger so this is showing somebody
actually in the process of shooting
knowing that this is now a violent thing
and removing that violence scene it's
it's at that level of crispness is what
ml operates at
another thing that he can do
reimagine your user inputs that's one
thing right you basically look at image
as Street images as bonafide inputs
think of speech as bonafide input your
input doesn't just need to be text right
that's what we normally think of you're
writing computer programs if they are
input is text it doesn't need to be text
anymore it can be images it can be audio
but the other thing that you may want to
think about is your business processes
themselves reimagine the way you do your
business process change your business
process what do you mean by that right
so if you're thinking about ml as a
rocket engine the thing that can take
you places their fuel is going to be
data you as long as you have data you
can go places with it so what are the
kinds of things that we're talking about
right you have typical customer journey
here you know what business processes
your typical customer journey is to go
look at any kind of manual thing that
you are doing and seeing if you can do
that man will think in a better way so
this is global fishing watch another GCP
customer and they basically would do
manual analysis of global fishing fleets
so the idea was that they would look at
the where the where the ships are
basically figure out how often these
ships had gone to a particular region to
basically see if that region was being
overfished whether somebody was fishing
about their quota whether somebody was
using the fish fishery resources more
often than they should whether they are
going into protected waters all of that
kind of stuff and they would do this
they had Manuel analysts kind of doing
this all the time okay some of that
stuff could be automated and that's what
they did
right so with machine learning you could
do you could basically take think of all
that man will a lot of things that were
done manually you couldn't make it
didn't automate the whole thing but they
could basically automate different
stages of it to basically then allow the
analyst to basically bring their
experience and expertise to the parts
that really mattered and this can make
the routine stuff so much more easier so
that it could be done with ml okay so
the typical customer journey often here
in
wolves find the things that your
analysts are doing the things that they
hate doing because it's just they come
in the morning and they're just doing
the same thing over and over again they
get tired because it's very repetitive
and there's the kinds of things that you
can automate because a you have the
results of all of that manual analysis
that stretches back many many many years
that's the key thing right you're what
you're thinking about is what can idea
that you have so you can actually
automate it so the data that you will
have is because you've done this
analysis in a manual way for so long
you basically may have five years 10
years 15 years how many years your
business has been around or how many
years your industry has been around of
the results of that manual analysis and
you can basically take all of the inputs
that go into the manual analysis and you
can take the outcome and you can train
an m/l model on it because all you need
is an input and the outcomes don't worry
about oh in order to do this this person
looked at this other thing and all of
that stuff that's fine right that may be
the way the human did it but the ml
model may be able to basically hone in
on other things that are representative
of the situations in know in concerned
but when you're talking about data right
you most of our data analysis as humans
most of our data analysis often we right
now if you go to look our data
scientists our data engineers our data
analyst in a company what can a data
there is are they dealing with
relational databases they're dealing
with structured data but in a typical
company
90% of your data will be unstructured
data or do you mean by unstructured data
emails
tons of information in your emails
reports lots and lots of information
when somebody goes to a field site and
writes a whole bunch of field notes what
are you doing with that data right now
it's your company's data but you can't
do anything with it because a you're
thinking I cannot actually put it in a
structured form so I can write a sequel
query on it right but that's where ml
can help the ml can help you find
insight from unstructured data but
unstructured data is hard unstructured
data is hard ok I did an ml bootcamp
yesterday again and we basically talked
about how to do structured data because
that's easy right that's when you're
doing a bootcamp you want to show people
how to do things like the lake know the
easy thing right let's just let's get
started with ml we'll get started with
structured data unstructured data images
speech text
those are hard those are very hard
that's where you basically go higher
PhDs to come do the work for you there
right but you don't need to do that all
the time because what you can do is that
you can take your unstructured data
whether it's images whether it's audio
whether it's video whether it's freeform
text and you can use the pre trained
models out of GCP the vision API for
images what is it going to do it's gonna
look at your image and tell you what's
in the image it's gonna tell you this D
it does this image has a mountain pass
in it this image has a dash and in it
etc right it's going to tell you what's
in it and you can also build on top of
our image models to basically classify
your own particular things but you want
to basically determine that this image
contains part number 83 41 no problem
right give us enough images of parts 83
41 and 83 48 and we can basically tell
you which ones which which ones a forage
screw and which one's a six inch screw
those are those are
pretty easy if you build on top of right
our models so you can do images that way
you have audio user speech API and you
basically take that and it'll give you
text so what do you do with the text
it's free font text well if you are free
from text use a natural language API so
what the natural language API will do is
a given freeform text it will tell you
who's mentioned what's mentioned the
sentiment it will tell you this is a
full sentence this is a phrase this is
these are the links between these things
and so on right so you can basically do
that you can do video there we just saw
that so all of those API is essentially
give you places labels people events
sentiment and at that point that is a
perfect thing to go ahead and feed into
your custom machine learning model and
now it's not as hard a problem anymore
okay because you're now dealing with
essentially structured data right and
you're basically deriving insight from
it we've done the hard part of going
from unstructured data to things that
you can now do your model training on
the third way that you can basically use
ml in your business is to delight your
users and what I mean by delight your
users is to basically figure out what
your users want before even they realize
they wanted it before do basically that
do that that spark of delight for
example right how many of you thought
that your email program had to suggest
to you what the response was going to be
but now write 20% of all users of like
inbox and now Gmail also has it right
20% of all responses on mobile to an
email start out with the smart reply hey
how many of you have used smart reply
okay still getting out there right 20%
it's still 20% basically the way it
works is you get an in email and the
email program inbox or Gmail suggests to
you three possible responses to that
email right so for example in this
particular email this guy says like you
know can you send me something and this
person right basically the the three
responses are one of them as I'm working
on them the second one is I just sent
them to you and the third one is no
plans yet okay three pretty good
responses that cover the spectrum so you
can start with that you basically saved
the person three words of typing
so this can apply to your business as
well right so if somebody comes and they
ring the bell in your grocery shop and
you already know that the location that
they're in the shelf is empty you can
actually delight them by saying we
realize that we are out of product X
would you like us to give you right
these are the three alternatives right
week you can take a raincheck we can
offer you a discount on another product
etc imagine how the users experience is
going to be different from right they
call in and we basically have them wait
and you basically know you have instead
of running them to the rigmarole the
moment they basically say I need help at
this point you basically realize what
help they need
because you know what they're currently
experiencing you guys you know we're
probably seeing some of that already
right these days when my flight gets
delayed like I automatically get
rebooked and the airline company is
already doing that that's the kind of
stuff that we're talking about right you
know what your customers experiencing
basically solve it right there right
don't you don't it's many things don't
have to go through the normal business
process if you know what they are you
can kind of know predict it okay so
here's another two to end the know in
terms of Lake now solving a problem that
you didn't know existed right in a
completely different fancy way okay lots
of people create their own home videos
right they make it and they want to put
a background music track on it when
you're putting a background music track
on that video what do what do people do
they go basically get a popular track
and it throw it onto the video and then
YouTube basically shuts it down because
of a copyright violation right because
you're using music that you shouldn't be
using but ml is now good enough that you
can basically go to a video and you can
visit you say I would like you to
generate music for me that's jazz that
is kind of low key for the first three
minutes it crescendos
between minutes 3 and 3:30 comes back
down and then basically ends with a
flourish and that music can get
generated
it'll be jazz it won't be like it won't
be winter more solace for any means but
it'll be pretty darn good for a home
video those are the kinds of things that
we're talking about right the world I'm
so excited about what ml can do I'm so
excited of what you guys can do with ml
so thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you